Das ist das Q&A zu meiner Reportage
über Scam auf dem Wohnungsmarkt.
Danke, dass ihr sie geschaut habt,
und danke für eure Kommentare.
Auf ein paar
gehe ich jetzt etwas genauer ein.
Viele von euch haben auch ihre Erfah-
rungen mit Scam-Inseraten geteilt.
Oldirty` schreibt z.B.:
Auch er wurde dazu aufgefordert,
rund 1'500 Fr. zu überweisen -
nur, um den Schlüssel zu bekommen,
um die Wohnung anschauen zu können.
Er schreibt:
"Das klingt jetzt schon sehr dreist,
aber komplette Geschichte
hörte sich damals fast plausibel an."
Ich denke auch, dass es
im Nachhinein sehr einfach ist,
zu sagen, dass das Inserat
unseriös geklungen hat.
Aber wenn man auf Wohnungssuche ist
und einen Tunnelblick hat,
nimmt man solche Inserate
etwas anders war.
So ging es zumindest mir
auf Wohnungssuche.
Ich meldete mich zwar nie
auf ein solches Scam-Inserat,
aber irgendwie denkt man trotzdem:
"Was, wenn's stimmt?"
"Was, wenn ich mir etwas entgehen
lasse und das d i e Traumwohnung
zu einem fairen Preis
in der Stadt Zürich wäre?"
Debbie schreibt, ihr habe man diesel-
be Geschichte wie Emily aufgetischt.
"Mein ungutes Bauchgefühl hat mich
schlussendlich davon abgehalten,
das Geld zu bezahlen."
Mega gut, dass du dich auf
deine Intuition verlassen konntest.
Unter Zeitdruck geht einem das
Bauchgefühl wohl manchmal verloren
und man wird anfällig
für betrügerische Inserate.
Auch Cyril schreibt,
ihm sei etwas merkwürdig vorgekommen.
Im Zweifel zu recherchieren und
zu googeln, ist genau das Richtige.
Danke für den Hinweis.
Auch Maria schreibt,
es könne helfen, sich im Vorfeld
zu den Preisen im jeweiligen Kanton
zu informieren.
So ist man weniger anfällig
für Fake-Inserate.
Sehr sinnvoll, sich vor der Wohnungs-
suche über die Preise zu informieren.
Auf Instagram
gab es eine andere Diskussion,
der Tenor in den Kommentaren
ist ein anderer.
Einige schreiben, sie fänden es naiv,
bei solchen Inseraten
Geld zu überweisen.
Klar, ich verstehe voll,
dass man denkt,
es ist nicht der schlauste Move,
einer Person Geld zu überweisen,
die man noch nie gesehen hat.
Jerumanda schreibt:
Es ist wichtig, zu unterscheiden: Es
war vielleicht eine naive Handlung -
nicht die ganze Person ist naiv.
Die Stadtpolizei Zürich sagt auch,
dass die meisten,
die auf solche Inserate reinfallen,
Austauschstudierende sind,
die die Preise nicht kennen,
vielleicht gar nicht
vor Ort sein können
und so zu leichter Beute werden.
Auch Emily aus der Reportage
findet im Nahhinein,
dass es etwas naiv war von ihr,
das Geld zu überweisen.
Würde sie wieder
auf ein solches Inserat stossen,
würde sie sich besser informieren.
Michael fragt sich, ob Polizei
und Politik nicht mehr tun könnten,
und wieso Airbnb
nicht einfach verboten wird.
Vielen Dank
für deine Frage zu Airbnb.
Im Fall von Emily war es ja so, dass
der Link, den sie bekommen hatte,
zu einer gefälschten Airbnb-Seite
führte.
Airbnb selbst
hat damit nichts zu tun.
Ganz unabhängig davon ist Airbnb
aber immer mal wieder in Kritik
im Zusammenhang mit Wohnungsmangel.
Wenn Wohnungen
als Airbnb vermietet werden,
können sie nicht als "normale"
Mietwohnungen genutzt werden.
Ein paar Regionen haben darauf
reagiert, z.B. der Kanton Genf.
Seit 2018 dürfen Wohnungen
nur noch max. 90 Tage pro Jahr
als Airbnb genutzt werden.
Und wegen der Polizei: Im Fall
von Emily sagte ihr die Polizei,
dass man in einem "kleinen" Fall
wie ihrem nicht mehr tun könne.
Sollten mehr Fälle zusammenkommen,
könne man das wieder verfolgen.
Die Kantonspolizei Zürich
hat auch eine Webseite,
auf der man sich melden kann, falls
man auf ein Inserat reingefallen ist.
Die seht ihr
in der Videobeschreibung.
Nick Name schreibt:
Ja, Nick Name, das ist es wirklich.
Ich höre nicht zum ersten Mal,
dass jemand ein Jahr,
eineinhalb oder zwei Jahre nach einer
Wohnung in der Stadt Zürich suchte.
Ich glaube, dass die letzte Hoffnung
oft Vitamin B ist,
weil der Wohnungsmarkt in Zürich
so ausgetrocknet ist.
Allgemein herrscht
laut dem Bundesamt für Wohnungswesen
in den Zentren und
den Agglomerationen Wohnungsmangel.
Wenn die Leerwohnungsziffer
unter 1 % liegt, wie in Zürich,
spricht man sogar von Wohnungsnot.
Das erklärt auch, warum in der Stadt
Zürich bei Wohnungsbesichtigungen
bis auf die Strasse
Menschen Schlange stehen.
Pas cal findet,
die Lösung sei Genossenschaft.
Ich gebe dir zur Hälfte recht.
Das stimmt sicher für einige -
gerade, wenn man langfristig
seine Zukunft in einer Stadt plant
und denkt, dass man
5, 10 oder 15 Jahre dort bleibt.
Man muss sich in einer Genossenschaft
ja anmelden und das kostet Geld,
z.T. mehrere Tausend Franken.
Das können sich
auch nicht alle leisten.
Und man kommt erst
auf eine Warteliste.
Bis man die Chance auf eine Wohnung
hat, können mehrere Jahre vergehen.
Das schreibt auch Marianne:
Das tut mir sehr leid. Ich hoffe,
dass das irgendwann noch klappt.
Zum Schluss fragt Silvan:
Vielen Dank für deine Frage, Silvan.
Ich bin leider
kein Paradebeispiel dafür,
wie man in der Stadt Zürich
eine Wohnung bekommt.
Ich sammelte monatelang Absagen,
obwohl ich ein ganzes Dossier hatte
mit CV,
angepasstem Motivationsschreiben,
Referenzen, Foto,
Betreibungsregisterauszug.
Aber das Ding ist:
Das ist the bare minimum.
Das machen in der Stadt Zürich alle.
Es ist wichtig, sich irgendwie
von der Masse abzuheben,
wie z.B. die WG im Film:
Sie schickten eine
PowerPoint-Präsentation von sich mit.
Einen Tipp habe ich noch,
auf den bin ich beim Recherchieren
zum Film gestossen:
Schaut
bei Anschlagsbrettern in Läden,
dort, wo alte Sachen und z.T.
auch Wohnungen inseriert werden.
Dort inserieren
anscheinend eher ältere Leute,
entsprechend
sind die Inserate nicht online.
Somit hat es
auch weniger Bewerber/-innen.
Ich wünsche dir viel Glück
und Ausdauer auf der Wohnungssuche.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Martina Riedi - 2022